So Leute ich bin wieder da, ich war in Ruhe auf dem Klo und hab was gegessen, hab ich mir gedacht, ist schon so spät,
machen wir einfach Stream wieder an, spielen noch ein paar Runden Battlefield, kurz was anklickshorn, ok, schauen wir mal, sollte eigentlich das Game starten,
so, dann gehen wir uns noch ein paar Runden Battlefield, mal gucken wie es läuft, mal schauen, mal kurz den Soundtrack aus, Lautstärke und so sollte eigentlich alles passen,
hab ich das letzte Mal schon eingestellt, diesmal hab ich auch geguckt, dass ich gleich die Bitrate hochgestellt hab, dass es nicht wieder kacke ausschaut,
erstmal ne Runde, bashen, alter bashen, oh perfekt, wir werden gleich schon wieder krass überrannt, alter wir kriegen,
ok, ich glaub ich weiß woran das liegt, Moment, ich glaub Punk Basta hat sich mal wieder nicht gestartet, wie startet man unter Windows Services,
äh, Service, Services, ja Lull, Alter, ok, ach ne, muss man mal so starten, ok, Admin,
der ist manual, hä, der ist automatic und der ist manual, alles klar, seems legit, keck, keck W, keck WWW, man muss nicht verstehen, ich hoffe jetzt gehts,
so, das ist übrigens auch das größte Problem was man hat bei Battlefield 3, wenn es abkackt, dann liegt das in der Regel daran, dass ihr keinen Punk Basta installiert habt,
das ist irgendwie fail, fragt mich nicht was da los ist, so, Alter, ich war ganz kurz weg und jetzt sind wir schon zweite Base am losen, äh, ich fass es nicht,
gedeist worden, ja, oh, oh, ich glaub wir kriegen grad richtig auf den Sack, mal gucken ob noch ein paar Leute kommen,
komm, wer fährt so ne Granate rein, alter, ok, ok, die Runde, die Runde ist verloren, ok, der Panzer hat geschossen, vielleicht kommen wir schnell durch,
ja, ja, ja, ja, nice, oh, ne, aber, äh, die Runde ist, die Runde ist RIP, reingeschollen auf den Sack gekriegt,
dass es nur noch Gun Game auf Siebertower gibt, da musst du den, du musst den Filter umstellen, ah, da ist er, der Fatal ist am Start, jetzt ist easy win, easy win,
Leute, easy win, Buitwurst 82, also, what the fuck, wo ist der dann am Start, wo ist Buitwurst, ey, du musst die Suche umstellen, mach alles raus,
also alle Häkchen komplett raus, auch bei den Games raus, und dann setz mal, dass du auf Rush suchst, alles raus machen, ok, die machen jetzt Überrennungsstellen hier gleich,
oh, da ist der Panzer, der Panzer ist am Start, wie, der ist nicht tot, Monarch, nur noch Gun Game, hä, hat eigentlich keinen Sinn, hallo, der hatte nicht mehr viel Leben, oder,
wir müssen, ey, wir müssen dahinter, wir müssen dahinter, die, die, die, die machen schon Legehenne, die machen schon Legehenne, bevor wir überhaupt da sind,
ich sag's euch, Monka Legehenne machen die, hallo, was ist hier los, hallo, kann man die Matchmaking, welche Matchmaking Zeit, du brauchst kein Matchmaking, du gehst einfach in den Surferbrowser und suchst den Surfer aus, auf dem du spielen willst,
Matchmaking, Matchmaking ist ja sowas von, von 2000, äh, 2020, das, das Game, das Game hat sowas, ich, ich, doch, wobei, das stimmt nicht, die haben Matchmaking, das stimmt nicht, dass die kein Matchmaking haben,
aber die brauchst kein Matchmaking, du gehst in den Surferbrowser und suchst dir was raus, kommst du, kommst du rum, Monkeys, juhu, oh, als hat er mir den Kopf geballert, ey, kann es der Max sein, der echte, nein, nein, nein, nein,
der ist es nicht, okay, wir switchen mal runter auf Engineer und machen mal hier den Objective Player, Massive Objective Player, der Porgas Objective Player, by the way, die können von hier hinten kommen, Team, ich weiß nicht, ob euch das klar ist,
aber die kommen gleich hier durch, sind das Schüsse, oder, was zum, warum fliegen hier Schüsse, warum kann mir das mal irgendjemand erklären, okay, oh, Huge Flank Leute, Massive Porgas Flank kommt jetzt, die Flank of Doom, leider habe ich die falsche Klasse für den Huge Flank, ich hätte, ich hätte, ich hätte Medic bleiben sollen, für den Huge Flank,
Massive Flanks,
ha, ha, ha, gepflankt und verloren, null, der Flank hat sich aber richtig gelohnt, Massive Huge Massive 500 IQ Flank, oh, ne, ne, ne, 360, Battlefield 3 ertrage ich nicht mehr,
was hatte das, 720p, wenn überhaupt, ne, ich glaube, ich glaube 680p oder sowas ganz scheppes, ne, ne, ne, Battlefield 3 ertrage ich nicht mehr, halt ich wirklich auf der 360 nicht mehr aus, 360 habe ich hier noch stehen, beste Konsole, ever,
okay, man kann sich überstreiten, der Super Nintendo war auch nice, aber insgesamt muss ich sagen Xbox 360, ich müsste, ich müsste auch mal so eine Tierlist machen hier, Konsole Tierlist, wie ist, wie ist der Friseur gemacht, das machen wir nachher noch,
sag euch da, da kommen die Sony Sachen aber bei mir nicht gut weg, also so viel wie Cyberpunk auf der One, ja, so ungefähr, ungefähr so wie Cyberpunk auf der Xbox One aussieht, Battlefield 3 auf der Xbox 360 aus, null,
ey, wo spawnen uns da, achso, dummer Spawn, dummer Spawn, okay, also entweder machen wir jetzt Big Play and Play links herum oder Big Play and Play, Big Play and Play rechts herum, ich würde sagen wir machen Big Play and Play links herum,
in der Hoffnung, dass die Gegner es nicht checken, Leute ich habe ein bisschen, what the fuck, ich wurde One Shot von der Smoke, wollt ihr mich rollen, wie das war kein Kill,
jawoll, jawoll, ich gehe da vorne hin, dass der Fatal rausballern kann, nice, nice, nice, nice, halten wir, halten wir, halten wir, sagen wir, irgendwie Spawn Gegner vor mir und sind auf einmal wieder weg, ich blick da nicht mehr durch,
hoffentlich gibt es Rats, Rats Beste, okay, ich muss hier durch, durch, okay, okay, okay, okay, was ist denn da drüben los, können eigentlich gar nicht mehr da sein,
hallo, Battlefield Suppression, hallo, oh, oh, huge, huge, massive, massive Rats, massive Rats, exquisite Rats, oh, fast, fast, oh shit, shit, shit, nice, okay, eines muss man sagen, die Noobs sind weg,
die Noobs sind weg, wir haben nur noch gescheite Gegner, aber wir haben Buitwurst 82, Buitwurst, nein, nein, lass mich in Ruhe, lass mich in Ruhe, Buitwurst, daneben,
okay, okay, es wird Zeit für Only High IQ Plays, ich sehe schon, also B ist auch kacke, also es dürfte eines der schwersten Bases im ganzen Spiel sein, geteilt mit, alter, ja, geil, geteilt mit Sand Crossing am Anfang B, ja, okay, nice,
MonkaS, was ist denn hier schon wieder los gerade, was ist denn hier schon wieder los, okay, erstmal alle den Kopf schießen, excellent, oh, nade, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, ich kann dich nicht ratzen da drin, Kollege, es geht nicht,
ey, die sind, die sind, die sind ja so heiß auf uns wieder, okay, mal kurz vorkriechen, dass mir das nicht so viel Damage macht, oh, oh, oh, oh, ja, Origin, beste, auch, nice, ich wollte ein bisschen Skama spielen, weil die habe ich quasi so gut wie nie gespielt, die habe ich letztens sogar erst unlocked,
okay, okay, ich, ich versuche mal, ich versuche mal, ich versuche den Big Brain Flank mal, aber das geht gerade nicht, die Skars suckt im Nahkampf, whoa, ja,
das Spicke, den gell, der ist aus dem Chat, nice, okay, wir müssen, wir müssen da von beiden Seiten reinstellen, sonst wird das nichts, ich spawn hinten und ich versuche nochmal reinzustellen auf die rechte Seite, das muss, muss, wir brauchen Pressure, Pressure von beiden Seiten,
Pressure, okay sobald die Granate explodiert, gehe ich rein, zack, ihr müsst spotten Jungs, spotted, spotted, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nein, Alter, in der Ecke steht er, die Noobs sind weg, Leute, ich sag es euch, die Noobs sind weg,
Ich brauche eine nade ich brauche eine neue granate und wir müssen von hinten gucken
Wir können jetzt wir können jetzt voll mit granaten zu zu bombardieren
Die brauchen die brauchen granaten einfach granaten einen kopf
Leute gibt mir eine granate refresh box please
Ich emt ich emt den scheiß oh fuck das geht ja gar nicht ich emt den kack ab hinten das nix kommt
fertig easy easy clap da ist also in dem moment wo ich die nade werfe
ne in dem moment wo ich die nade werfe ist kommt da kommt da raus nice lull mashfield
die lassen sich ein bisschen lassen sich gut wegspringen die gehe ich nach ok ok ok
jetzt ok wir können ich glaube wir können ich glaube das geht jetzt auf hoffentlich habe
ich gutes timing please gif gif gutes timing gif gutes timing
auf bein sein fühlt die sich nicht automatisch auf wat alter falle der
retz train ist am start guck es euch an guck es euch an
retz tot retz tot retz tot so muss es sein so wo ist der fatal der fatal
stellst noch da vorne rum oh nee buntwurst ich hatte gestern abend so
nice ist team mit mit auch zu zwei ehemaligen belphi 3 hardcore sucht
dann wir haben so geschreckt die geht da alter wo seid ihr denn alle ok ich kann
er jetzt nicht raus jeder hat nicht drauf alter ich sehe ich weiß auch nicht mal
wo der du überhaupt ist ja ich mache mal hier ich mache mal bet ich mache mal
bet
ey das war der ansinne bin erstaunt wie gut du noch bist dankeschön
da fehlt mir viel unglaublich viel übung aber dazu kommt dazu kommt mal zur
ehrenrettung der gegner dass so die richtig krassen leute auch glaub ich gar
nicht mehr spielen ok aber eins ohne scheiß leute die nup sind
weg die nups fliegen auch nicht mehr den heli die nups sind einfach weg
ich sehe da nix monka es
da fuck
das ist ja echt der wahnsinn also das definitiv keine nupp gegner
obw ist es noch da sehr gut oder schön
ok wenn er clever es geht jetzt irgendwie ums haus rum
ok das probieren wir zwar wir machen jetzt big brain big brain play only big brain
play ist leute da trüben ist weil da trüben war was was mit dem gegner los
eigentlich will ich ins haus ich will ins haus
lass mich ins haus lass mich ins haus die leute bei mir spawnen auch wir haben
b gelegt
oh nice massive
seh nix
könnt ihr sterben please die defusen gerade die defusen gerade wo ist
der wo ist der dude
ich habe mich wo das ok easy clap easy clap oder war einer
der denkt jetzt achtung weil es massive mind games der denkt jetzt gilings rum
und jetzt und jetzt g bade g g g bade
wo ist der pence mann der ist einfach weg
der panzer ist einfach abgehauen hat ich gesagt ne g bade gibt es nicht mehr
achtung jolo jolo jawoll jawoll ok jetzt können wir links ist irgendwas leute
links ist definitiv hier muss ja peak action machen wie ein cs alter was ist
denn hier gerade los ist doch nicht normal ist doch nicht normal alter
was der her ist das ist das noch bettel viel drei was wir gerade spielen oder ist
es schon das neue cs ok liegt in der box hier legt ne box eine exzellente box ok
ich push mal mit dem tank bleibt ja nichts anderes bricht vorsichtig ok außer
der außer der tank verpisst sich
in den tank reno so geht das nicht so funktioniert das nicht tank tank mann
den rett sich nicht den kann ich nicht retten links links links ich verstehe
gar nicht von wo hey marx hallo kiesel nie kies kies kies kauer ok die base ist
auch brutal die base ist richtig hart ohne panzer kommst hier nicht durch du
brauchst den big brand pence mann dass es hier funktioniert exzellent pence mann
guckt euch an gestern hatte ich einen mit einem trigger makro am start im game
der hat ein 490 mit no recoil trigger makro gespielt zwar auch geil du hast
irgendwo den kopf raus gestreckt tot inzudaun alter die wollen es aber
wissen die wollen die sind die sind heiß die sind
echt heiß
die sind die sind ganz scharf auf uns wir sollten versuchen rechts zu pushen
wir sollten versuchen andere seiten durch zu pushen irgendwie das wird nix
also du brauchst hier einen guten panzer mann wenn du keinen panzer mann hast
wird das nix ich sehe ich sehe da drüben übrigens nix
ok fettel ich versuchte ich mal
alter die ars wall macht damage da ist noch einer hinter
monka die sind so scharf die gegner alter die sind so scharf
die sind richtig scharf die gegner die sind ganz ganz scharf
hyper scharf sind die da muss der hier du musst dir die griechen mann machen ok
gefällt ich hab dich ich hab dich ich hab dich
fack nae emt ich muss runter nae emt krass nae emt habe ich den
hier ist nichts mehr oder rechts alter da gehen wir jetzt rein
nein das wäre der multikill des jahrtausends geworden das wäre der
multikill des jahrtausends geworden habt ihr gesehen wie sie alle auf einer
linie gestanden haben ich meine es waren jetzt schon drei mit dem halben
akaziel den bämbel bämbel bämbel hättest du richtig schläge gegeben
der multikill des jahrhunderts hättest du gegeben aber da ist mal eine nade rein
die gegner sind echt nicht schlecht oh nice nice huge massive net
16 monat sehr gut sie nur ich kann gerade keine emotes drücken aber auch mist
ich wollte emotes drücken dankeschön für die subs ok leute die gegner sind echt
nicht dumm die sind wirklich nicht dumm
fädelisch eben ab vorne
kann ich jetzt kann ich jetzt big brain flank machen geht jetzt big brain flank
der panzer panz man ist da achtung
das konnte man kaputt schießen
ja ja panzer bleibt stehen
panzer weiter die klinge auf den zack die klinge auf den zack in your face
panzer ich kann nicht weiter runter
massive smoke big brain smoke jetzt will das wissen jetzt jetzt macht er
ernst jetzt macht er ernst der panzer fahrer
vorher hatte einfach nur zu beten jetzt jetzt holt er den smoke aus jetzt jetzt
macht er ernst
dumme ist nur mit dem smoke sehe ich halt auch nix
ok ok easy easy win easy win leute drüben stirbt alles aber guck mal ist nur noch
ein mkomm noch ein mkomm links spawn was rechts spawned auf
das ist das ist aber gute runde gut und egal ob wir gewinnen oder verlieren
nicht sterben nicht sterben nicht sterben nicht sterben ja und exzellent exzellent exquisite
jawoll sehr gut nice jungs nice habt ihr gut gemacht sehr schön so muss das sein
endlich endlich mal ein bisschen hier intense runden aber ein paar gegner auch
mal ein paar gegner die was taugen boitwurst bester name
und ihr wisst ja ihr wisst ja leute wenn man gewonnen hat egal wie knapp und
es war ja es war ja knapp ihr wisst es ist immer also ich gewinnt
egal wie knapp es ist immer easy immer gg it's
gut dass wir das geklärt haben und heck wenn der gegner gewinnt wie gesagt ich
hatte gestern echt ein typ am start der hatte ich across the map dauer feuert
an 490 in den kopf also ich glaube noch nicht mal dass ein aimbot hat ich glaube
da hat er sich ganz gut geahmt der hatte einfach ultra krass ist noch recall triggermarkup für
die an 490 oh je oh jetzt wird es jetzt wird anstrengend leute
pass mal auf pass mal auf pass mal also high iq play reicht für die ganze sache jetzt schon
gar nicht mehr was wir jetzt gleich machen wir machen jetzt monka giga iq play zeige
euch das mal die gegner müssten aber mitmachen
fack warum ok ok ok achtung achtung huge nein nein fack ich bin zu spät
bin zu spät normalerweise ist das echt oh das ist das beste play wenn du ungefähr mit dem
timing zur seite an den felsen läuft wenn dies ein licht stream japp japp japp definitiv wenn
dies wenn dies ein licht stream jetzt wenn die mörser rauskommt ich mag schon auf die
die die drücken gut die drücken gut die gegner monak es aber ich sag euch diese posi an dem
felsen wenn du da mit dem richtigen timing timing nehmen reinläufst bämb bäb dann ist
ok wo ist der typ der oder ist auch im spielplatz wir müssen weg wir müssen weg wir müssen weg
was ist hier mit die gehts dann grad los guckt euch das mal vor vor die abdeckung gehen ich
wollte big brain flank machen und ich dachte mir die aim links e ab jetzt müssen wir jetzt müssen
wir oh shit ok das war es jetzt ist auch weg metro ist so ein ding metro die erste base die
kann extrem schwer sein zu kriegen oder was der instant ganz ganz merkwürdig wo sind die denn
immer ssf ist das solo self found leg ja metro support also du kannst du kannst hier übelst
reinspringen die also die gegner drücken wirklich krass das ist jetzt nicht so dass
das irgendwelche kankenup gegner sind die sind nicht ohne der typ ist hier hinter der mauer ist
klar die fuß die fuß man kannst du voll vergessen ich würde dich retten aber ich
komme nicht raus die treffen richtig was die treffen richtig was
so jetzt die große preisfrage
wo gehen wir hin ok wir machen den fronten den frontalangriff wie es aussieht aber das mag
ich nicht das mag ich nicht das mag ich gar nicht ich mach mal erstmal flank action die
sind bestimmt schon da die jungs naht und gegen die p90 dachte nicht dass die schon hier an der
ecke an der ecke stehen die machen das auch geschickt mit smoke da sieht man mal das bringt
richtig was oh fack falsche richtung
ok irgendwo in der ecke hier ist schon auch was
die sind echt aggressiv die gegner und es sind keine noob gegner was ist denn hier los
gleich serverwechsel danach easy easy einfach dortchen einfach gegner dortchen
was willst du machen die sind wirklich krass drauf die jungs
also sie wirklich hat drauf die gegner
ok also mehr konnte ich jetzt gerade nicht das ging nicht die die drücken auch voll
ok die base ist auch schwierig wenn wir uns nicht gar so doof anstellen ist das ist die base haltbar
solange wir es nicht instant verlieren bevor die leute reingespornt sind und nicht gleich
rauspushen wie die letzten deppen ich bleibe mal ein bisschen definitiv und man kann das
holst ihr weg machen ich kriege die alle nicht tot
das sind zu viele das sind zu viele fack die die pushen die pushen viel zu krass durch die
kriegste die muss einmal komplett wegsprayen dass die erst mal ein bisschen in stocken
kommen das sind aktuell viel zu viele auf einmal der lebt wieder ok also mehr reinsprayen geht
nicht mehr reinsprayen geht gerade nicht fack von hinten shit wie kommt denn dahin
die sind echt hart drauf aber aber noch
der typ irritiert mich ok ok ok wir müssen mal links gucken links der typ ist auf fack
die sind nehmen wir das mal voll ist noch noch nix da kommt nur raus
oh nee alter ich kann nur in eine richtung gucken vergiss es was soll ich denn machen
die nehmen uns so übertrieben auseinander ist wir unten in die ecke durchs bild gelaufen
ok naja gut da machst nix da machst nix achten achten achten achten nein munival just defuse
feifett das ist nicht vorher das ist mindestens feifett ich würde schon fast sagen 11 hat
das ist das ist genauso wie just win das ist auch so und und chat ihr wisst ja ihr wisst
ja also eine sache wo man in in overwatch channels übelst geil die leute triggern kann
ist wenn du schreibst don't write in chat if you are not high elo gold plus das ist
ja der tritt die troll copypasta schlechten da reagieren alle drauf only high elo messages
gold plus fack ich dachte ich krieg den hier geaimt only high elo messages das bedeutet
in battle field 3 alle die m16 und 416 spielen dürfen nicht dürfen nicht posten ich natürlich
ausgenommen weil ich mein mich kann ja keiner dran hindern gucken ob die nade was was
reißt trifft eins ganz gut in gang ok die sind garantiert hier noch am start die uns
lebt er tut noch lebt er noch dahinten mein hier lebt er noch nein ok ich muss weg leute
die kommen jetzt hier die kommen jetzt hier wurde wieder belebt oder zockt er einfach
nur so man weiß es nicht man weiß es nicht ok mehr geht es nicht mehr geht es nicht
mehr geht es nicht mehr geht es nicht mehr geht es nicht mehr sagt es ist keine
Ich komm mir echt vor wie ein CS hier, wie du um die Ecke laufen musst
M320 Flashbang, oh ja das wäre nice hier, guck mal der T-Bagged mich, hat er mich gerade
Leute, Leute, hab ich mich da jetzt verguckt? Hat er mich gerade geteabagged?
Keck Quadruple U, hat er mich T-Bagged? Hat er mich T-Bagged? Anzeige ist raus, ich ruf jetzt
direkt in DICE Stockholm an. What the fuck? Ich ruf jetzt direkt in Stockholm an bei DICE,
dass du wirst gebannt, easy. Okay, okay, gehen wir mal hier rein. Ja erschreckt mich halt mehr
please. G18, G18, 0, OP, kacke. Oh shit, shit, shit, shit, alle uns alle weggesprayt. Musste sein,
wenn man der Lobby ist, ja stört mich nicht. Pog, Pog, T-Bagged, please more. More T-Bagged,
please. Buitwurst, ich find den Namen irgendwie übertrieben halt, Achtung. G18, G18, stellts.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, alter, alter, piss dich. Okay, get nix, oh get nix.
Mein Vater arbeitet bei EA, der bant ich. Was? Nur bei EA? Eine Mutter bei Microsoft, Vater bei EA,
Onkel bei Ubisoft, Bruder bei DICE? Ich hab die ganze Familie verteilt, die wird überall gebannt.
Alles, alles weggebannt. Oma bei Punkbuster, Opa bei Wack, wobei das ja schwachsinnig ist,
weil das nicht die Hersteller sind, aber gut. Ey. Es ist nicht normal, die Gegner, aber wir halten
doch ganz gut dagegen, oder? Der Opa bei Steam, Opa hat Steam programmiert. Nice, wir werden
eingenebelt, excellent. Ich schieß einfach nur auf Marker jetzt. Ich schieß jetzt einfach nur
auf Marker. Hier ist irgendwo was, passt auf, ich sag euch, der sitzt noch an der Ecke. Okay,
jetzt pull pull pull pull pull pull pull pull pull pull pull pull pull. Neiiin. Okay. Bei der Base
läuft es erstaunlich gut, aber ich komm nicht mal aus dem Spawn raus, das suckt. Wahrscheinlich,
Das ist wahrscheinlich Spawn Rapen sonst einfach nur jetzt just for fun
Oh bist fatal fuck
Aber Buitwurst hat gute
Gute
Guck, wann kommt der um die Ecke der Dude?
Wann kommt der Dude hier um die Ecke?
Wo ist er?
Ich seh nix mehr
Please
Da ist er
Ich, Leute, ich bleib jetzt einfach hier
Ich bleib jetzt einfach hier hinter crouched
Ich bleib jetzt hier einfach crouched die ganze Zeit, einfach crouched hier in der Ecke
Im Bus
Der Busman
Okay, vielleicht, vielleicht gewinnen wir die Runde
Man, wir müssen den Busman bashen
What the fuck, ins den Kopf
Meine Güte, jetzt könnten sie eigentlich Legehände machen
Oh nice, nice
Oh, ich, ich helf unserem Dude
Ach, wir haben schon defused
Okay, das war dumm
Das war dumm
Ich hätte da nicht hinten, aber das war dumm
Das war richtig, richtig pepega move
Ich dachte, wir haben noch nicht defused, hätte ich die lieber mal davon abgehalten, zu neu zu planten
Okay, das war's Leute, vorbei, vorbei
Easy, Hände hoch, wir haben verloren
Hände hoch
Ich ergeb mich
Zu viel, zu viel auf einmal
Gg Eats, ja, immer, immer wenn man gibt, immer Gg Eats
Easy mit Hacks würde ich sagen, ja
Hätten wir einen Hacker, hätten wir auch gewonnen
F, ja, genau
Alles Hacks, sag ich doch, was sonst
Alles Hacks
Die letzte M-Core war echt anstrengend
So, dürfen wir jetzt nochmal attacken Metro, gegen das Team Metro attacken stelle ich mir sehr anstrengend vor
Okay, wir müssen jetzt volle Pulle Attack Action machen
Links rum, an der Mauer, ich geh jetzt links rum an A an die Mauer
Community Game, ja, du kannst join
Was? Da ist nichts gestorben
Lol, by the way habt ihr mein Chebat mitgekriegt mit links an die Mauer
Ich hab gedacht falls, falls irgendwie einer
Hatsch, Hatsch, Hatsch
Hatsch, Hatsch
Ich hab mein Chebat mitgekriegt mit links an die Mauer, ich hab gedacht falls, falls irgendwie einer
Irgendwie einer guckt im Stream
Und dann sag ich einfach, ich geh links
Und ich gar nicht links gehe, ha, ha, Meta-Chebat
Hatsch, Hatsch, Hatsch
Der Chat, was ist eigentlich im Chat schon wieder los? Hacker-Mats
Ja, Fatal, Fatal, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut, hier ist nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice
Excellent, excellent, excellent
Da oben ist irgendein Dude
Hoffentlich will ich, ich wollte, ich komm da nicht hin, sonst würd ich dich retzen
Okay, okay, let's go, easy
Der weiß, dass ich rumkomme
Guck mal, da wird wieder der Team backt
Habt ihr gesehen, mein Big Brain Announcement, ich hab gesagt, ich geh links lang im M kommen, alle geiern sind links an B, an A
Und was macht der Max? Der läuft einfach zu B
Jebaited
Ich komm mir hier grad echt vor wie ein CS
Bist ja am Ecken abcampen, extrem
Ist Suppression immer noch OP? Ja, gut, das ist halt Kernbestandteil in dem Game
Nee, die Taschenlampe nicht, die Taschenlampe spielt niemand
Fatal nicht sterben, perfekt
Die Taschenlampe spielt niemand, Taschenlampe suckt
Taschenlampe suckt
Wir können doch nicht so ran stürmen, ich komm grad nicht vorwärts
Die Unused Voice Lines, oh ja, das wär Pog
Oh fuck, ich spiel voll nett, mein Lieblings Voice Line ist ja immer noch
I get fucked in the ass over here
Beste Voice Line
Help, I get fucked in the ass over here
Der CS-up-aim-champ ist strong
Was soll ich denn machen, ich kann nicht vorwärts, sobald ich vorwärts gehe
Ok, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, smoke, smoke, Reno
Wallbang, wallbang, Nate, Achtung, wallbang, Nate, Poggers, Poggers
Ah fuck
Jaaa, wir müssen da einmal richtig, richtig krass durchpushen
Richtig massive Push machen müssen
Einen massiven Push vollführen
Ah
Alter Leute, was ist denn hier los, ich verpiss mich wieder
Ich verpiss mich wieder, das ist zu viel
Das ist zu viel
Oh shit, jetzt kommen sie mit der Shotgun um die Ecke
No homo vergessen, immer No homo dabei
Das war ja mal eine Zeit lang, so wie man heute Digger sagt, hat man früher immer irgendwas gesagt, gleich den No homo
So ey, du spielst ja aber gut No homo
Oh, jetzt geht eher scheiß los
Ihr krasser Spawnrape, Spawnrape, No homo
Was von Spawnrape überhaupt noch sagen, ich meine Zeiten wo blind playthrough gebannt wird, das kann man bestimmt Spawnrape nicht mal sagen
Bestimmt Toss, ist bestimmt so krass gegen Toss das Wort Spawnrape zu verwenden
Es ist ja auch ein bescheuertes Wort
Irgendwo hinterm Baum, irgendwo hinterm Baum war er
Alter, der Zombie Train
No Offense ist auch geil, Alter du dummer Kackspass
No Offense und No homo
Und No homo
Oh Moment, war da grad ein Gegner, war da, war, war, sag mal, weil bin ich blind oder war da unten ein Gegner
Okay, guckt sie euch an, guckt sie euch an
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nein
Nein, jetzt hätten wir draufpushen müssen, jetzt hätten wir draufpushen müssen, jetzt wo wir sie gerade
Oh, lege Hände, lege Hände
No homo, lege Hände
I get fucked in the ass over hier, würde ich sagen
Help, I get fucked in the ass over hier, aber richtig in die ass hat er gerade gekriegt
Wie viel Uhr, wenn ich es unleashed, nope
Eigentlich eine coole Runde, nehmen wir mal auf, F10
Hier ist irgendwo noch einer, lol, da liegt er
Wie du neifst den nicht, ne, hab ich keine Reactions mehr in Battlefield
Ne, da hab ich keine, ich mein, man ist F-Tor, da hab ich keine Reactions mehr für, kein Muscle Memory, wie man so schon sagt
Du Sack, haha, ihr seid eindeutig bessere Team, ihr gewinnt das easy
Ich würde dich ja eigentlich retten, okay, Yolo Rats, Yolo Rats, easy, worse, worse, worse
Es war es wert, es war es wert, easy, easy, win
E, jawoll, Rats, RP, farm, äh, nicht RP, ihr wisst, was ich meine, Rats, Punkte, farm
Rats, Rats, Punkte
Ich hab nicht mehr viel, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, kommst du raus, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam
Ich hab ein Problem, sag mal ist da oben einer drauf
Alter, die Runde ist so krass, ey, was ist mit denen allen los, die spielen hier voll um ihr Leben
Ist das, ist das, ist das Black Ops Skill-Based Matchmaking oder was
Haben die sich jetzt gedacht, okay, wir machen in Battlefield nichts mehr, aber Skill-Based Matchmaking bauen wir ein
Du kommst dir ja fast wie im ranked vor, definitiv nicht normal
Ich mach die Rats-RPs hier, ein Ding, easy, easy, Rats, easy, Rats, easy, Rats, easy, live
Nein, wo kommt denn der Dude her
Ja, Skill-Based Matchmaking, neun Jahre altes Game eingebaut, ja easy
Die machen mich, die Gegner sind so übertrieben aggressive drauf, normalerweise pushen Gegner überhaupt nicht in dich rein in dem Game
Ich mein, die machen das schon richtig, aber das ist nicht normal, das ist nicht normal
Was, was? Alter, also der hat mich eben echt krass verarscht, oder? Der ist ja einfach nur in das Bild gehüpft
Der ist da hochgesprungen, hochgesprungen, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog
Ich hab imètement in dieses Bild gehüpft, der ist da hochgesprungen, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog, flog
Ich komm' vor.
Die Rätts APs werden gefarmt, Leute.
Da war jetzt nicht klar von wo oder was kommt, aber die Bälzer.
Das Problem ist, das Kicker-Team ist ein Ticken besser und die Base ist wirklich brutaler.
Jetzt kommen sie mit der Shotgun.
Das ist definitiv nicht normal, was hier abgeht.
Ich komm' hier echt falsch, spiele ich CS oder sowas in der Richtung?
Du bist hier nur am Ecken ab, Aym.
Du bist echt nur am Ecken ab, Aym.
Leute ihr kommt, ihr kommt hier nicht raus, sag ich euch.
easy, easy win, passt auf, oh nein ich wollte ihn messern, ich wollte ihn messern und es ging
nicht, ich wollte ihn messern, das saurus meister, ok weißt was, weißt was wir jetzt machen, ich
mache jetzt den pockflank, den pockflank auf du, hallo, nope, oh das war nicht der pockflank,
aber fast, es war on the way to the pockflank ey, pass mal auf hier, nein, nein, nein, nein,
ok das ist keine gute, mp5, mach mal 360, nö warum, wozu soll ich jetzt, soll ich jetzt
einfach geradeaus laufen und im kreis drehen oder wie, ja easy, oh nee, oh nee, oh nee,
jetzt müssen wir aufpassen, oh ich sag's euch, wir müssen jetzt darüber durchballern und
immer, oh nein, nein, nein, nein und immer schön spotten in smoke, immer schön in smoke
spotten, jetzt haben sie es, jetzt haben sie es und ich bin ich, und ich bin ich gespawnt
am Anfang, das war, weil ich das zeigen musste, pock, pock, pock, pock, pock, pock, pock,
wallbang nade, wallbang nade, ok keiner mehr da, keiner mehr da, wir müssen da rüber
gucken, da drüben darf nix lang ey, wie sie da durch treffen, ok leute ich geh mal kurz
auf die andere seite das abchecken, ich hab da so meine bedenken, da ist ein dude von
uns, leert, leert, woah alika bam, nochmal, nochmal ratz ich komm noch ein stückchen
zurück, komm noch ein stückchen zurück, please, please, please, please, please, nice, nice,
jetzt komm, komm, komm, komm, jawoll, excellent, excellent, oh nee, jetzt sind sie drüben,
pock, ich muss auch gucken, wenn die hier rauskommen, nice, oh oh, oh oh, pock, scheiße,
das war es jetzt, jetzt vorbei, battlefield 4 kam viel zu früh, ja seh ich auch so, seh
ich ganz genauso, wie gesagt battlefield 3 zum service game, 3, 2, 1, excellent, wir
halten das erstaunlich gut leute, wisst ihr das, häsel ich kann dich da nicht ratzen,
das ist voll in the line hier, oh fire, oh oh jetzt kommen sie von links, ey ich blick
hier grad absolut nicht mehr durch, von wo, woher wissen die dudes überhaupt wo ich rumsteh,
guckt euch mal an, the fuck, jetzt haben sie es, jetzt haben sie es, alter was, gespäme,
das gespäme ey, guck mal, ich hab kaum kills gemacht, nur 3 spillionen assists, da schimmeln
sie, schimmeln sie an B rum, der läuft wieder da rum, ja aber was willst du sonst machen,
ok komm wir spielen, wir machen objective mode, wir machen objective, wir gehen anti,
anti tank, guckt euch den chat an, guckt euch den chat an, gg eats my ass, der panzer
schon gespawnt, jetzt spawn der panzer, jetzt spawn der panzer, pansman kommt, achtung, ok
ich hab keine ahnung wo der panzer genau ist, irgendwo da, wo ist der panzer, ist der hier
noch im wisch, ich versuch den panzer zu killen, ja auf panzer, jetzt traut sich der panzer
nett, ich fass es nett, sonst, oh jetzt, ey die trücken krass rein, du musst dich
an dieser stelle in dem gang halten, sonst geht da erstmal nix, ok ich bleib mal, wir
machen objective mode, objektive mode, oh bamm habt ihr gesehen, habt ihr die rakete
gesehen, wie nice die getroffen hat across the map, fuck, br also firestorm war das beste
an belfin, hab ich jetzt schon von einigen gehört, ich habs nie ausprobiert, ok ich
muss killen, ich muss killen, solange wenn ich nix kille es sackt, ich kann nicht objective
mode machen, schön alter, ach fuck da ist ja gar keine tür
von hinten oder
ja na klar, ok ich muss auf jeden fall sturmsoldaten bleiben, leute wusste das ich dachte am anfang
medics halten mehr aus als der rest, äh nicht medics, supporter, man kann ja aufs dach,
ich dachte am anfang supporter halten mehr aus als der rest, weiß nicht so genau warum
wahrscheinlich weil die so gepanzert aussehen, ist aber gar nicht so, es soll auch schwach
sein, moment wir haben beides, wir haben beides entschärft bekommen, oh nein, what, alter
ich war ja mal so um die eck, achtung yolo modus, yolo modus activated, nice, lul, oh
oh der panz man, der panz man, oh wir haben den panzer geklaut, nice, wir brauchen was
zum retten, ok jetzt müssen wir auf andere seite gucken, ok ich geh zu b, oh ich muss
da rauf, ich muss da rauf, ich muss da rauf, kommt her, kommt her, nice, ich mach die runde
nur assists, assists, assists gameplay only, guckt euch mal an die punkte, nur von assists,
ok, ok, achtung yolo modus, ich kann hier nicht weg, sobald ich hier weggehe, sobald
ich hier weggehe ist rip, ich will die eigentlich flanken, nice, oh da kommt der panz man, oh
fuck, ok jetzt sind sie, jetzt sind sie ran, nice, so flank action hat aber nichts gebracht,
jetzt haben sie, jetzt haben sie es da, guck vielleicht gehen wir den panzer down, hit, jaja,
jawoll, cross the map, wir müssen gucken das jetzt, sag mal was ist mit dem panzer los,
warum lässt er dich so easy hitten, lulw, ok jetzt müssen wir gucken das hier in der
mittenx lang kommt, rpg on inf, kack noob, lul, rpg on inf, lul, da wirst du immer geflammt
für früher, ok ich brauch mal was zum nachladen, da kommt der panz man, panz man ist am start,
oh aua aua, stop it, stop it, der panzer tot, bam, hit, na gut das bringt jetzt auch nichts
ich bräuchte mal ne muni, liegt hier irgendwo ne muni kiste, hier liegt ne muni kiste oder,
nice, oh der hat ja die massive big brain poggers poosie aller Zeiten, einfach mal ein
smoke spray, nice, allen
gibt mir eine granate alda gibt mir eine granate aus dem pack ich brauche eine granate für die
zwei dudes gegenüber achtung achtung die melde passt mal auf hier pockers nade und und und bam
ok ich sehe ich sehe gar nichts mehr ok panzer ok so war das nicht geplant leute ich sage ich
euch ehrlich rpg oder inf mir jetzt ein abs mir vollkommen egal ob das nupe ist oder nicht
scheiß drauf juckt mich überhaupt nicht ob das nupe ist juckt mich so nicht ob das nupe ist
die grämer schließlich gewinnen das voll reingerannt nur ab das gesehen das um die
eckigen komponieren die raketenwerfer in die fresse gekriegt nur weh disabled jetzt drauf
jetzt drauf macht die platt fack ich hab probiert ich habe noch eine rakete gegeben aber oh ne der
hat hier 30 milliaren rap typen am starten jetzt bin ich tot das sagt fack ich guck mal
leute der max stirbt der max stirbt m.com verloren so ist es so ist es einfach ist jetzt
hier die die wahrheit revealed
nice sehr gut gemacht hier pockers team pockers team
mit der welche durch gepusht auch ich glaube da sind welche durch gepusht
gibt es hier wo ist die muni box wo ist die muni box braune muni box muni box muni
box bis vor andere seite die sind durch gepusht
da ist in der mitte einer drin kann das sein
ich bin nicht sicher ob da einer durch gerannt ist nein fack
ripp vielleicht kriege ich ein ratz wäre auf jeden fall nice nice nice pockers pockers
m.com ist auch krass hier das ist auch wirklich schwer der panzer ist durchgefahren oder
in der fress die suppression ist richtig brutal da sitzt er Richtung andere m.com scheiß drauf
wir müssen einfach nur b halten meinte ich eigentlich der panzer lässt sich gut
halten
panzer was warum halten die panzer eigentlich so krass viel aus
weil ich habe da sonst was reingehämmert jetzt
die panzer ist leer sich das richtig die sind auf der brücke ok jetzt ist jetzt ist jetzt
die overwatch taktik die pushen jetzt noch mal alle die pushen jetzt alle noch mal
overwatch taktik easy win easy win leute wenn wir das einfach halten einfach halten anstrengend
echt anstrengend gg eats eats wir haben gewonnen also ist es aus prinzip easy game of my life
der panzer guy hat wirklich nix gerissen hey bei da hast aber recht der panzer typ war
wirklich kacke der panzer typ der hatte gefühlt 20 engineers hinter sich und der ist nicht
schlecht hier abdeck hat gar nicht gesehen weil chat eingeblendet ist zeit mal deine
aufträge please äh manst die ich hab kaum was anlockt auf dem pc ähm wo sind das nochmal
der falsche richtung schlecht
anspringen schreckt max schreckt lasst sie bloß nicht rätseln äh äh was war was war
sie nicht rätseln jawoll jetzt bäm jawoll nice äh wo sind wir hier hä ach wir sind
im spawn alter sagt es mal einer ok da machst du nix nein links links rum machst du nix
das by the way willkommen bei einem der heftigsten helmkommens im ganzen game hätt ich jetzt
nen granatwerfer dabei kann ich probieren da oben das ding runter zu ballern kommt die
rate gut der dao typ ist wieder da hackblock der dao typ ist der shotgun man ist wieder
da achtung achtung achtung ey das ist wieder der wahnsinn warum kommt finis an die stiop
nice ich freu mich schon richtig nice du freu du ich mach ich mach den team champ up aim
up aim champ der up aim champ ist am start
ich will nur sicher gehen dass da keiner kommt von da
jetzt wo ich nicht hingucke ne jetzt wo ich nicht hingucke jetzt er da
glaub ich kann er da ich brauch granate ich brauch ne granate gib mir ne granate aus dem
midi pack ihr wisst was ich mein ich mein nix nachfüll pack gib mir ne granate alter
nachfüll pack please gib mir ne granate jetzt so jetzt mit schmugges und wenn das ding explodiert
bamm jawoll haben wirs geknackt
denkt dran hier oben kann keiner respawn sagt das einfach nur zu mir selbst gerade easy easy
ist m kommen aller Zeiten ja das bringt euch jetzt auch nix mehr leute wenn ihr das so reingesprayt
next please
nein alter warum warum sitzt jetzt so du drinnen der nicht mal reppen kann
ok alles gut alles gut alles gut ich hab nix gesagt aber ich mach trotzdem repair champ
ich mach repair champ repair champ ist unterwegs bisschen abwechslung heute repair champ kommt
achten nicht sterben schweißbrenner champ ist am start
wie gefällt ihr eigentlich der crossbar ich glaub den hab ich auf dem pc nichtmal unlockt
ja reparierungsman lass mich reparieren
nein bleib da ich muss mich irgendwo dahinter verstecken
für das team hier ist gut hier ist gut hier sehe ich was und keiner sieht mich excellent
sehr gut
lass mich hinter den panzer jawoll
teamplay beste und nebenbei noch best champ das müsst ihr erst mal nachmachen
oder kommt gleich was links
ich habe keine ahnung wo der dude ist
schweiß champ
nicht mal dritter sitzplatz doch die haben eigentlich den dritten sitzplatz eben waren
drei drinnen
high octane repair gameplay hier kann mir irgendeiner erklären was das war gerade
man
ist echt schwer zu reparieren
ich stelle es dem jetzt einfach nur hinterher
ich muss halt auf der seite bleiben dass ich mit den gegnern nicht sind nein panz man
lass mich nicht allein
ok panz man jetzt hast du verloren
high octane repair gameplay
aber das bringt aber springen paar punkte aber kills bringen definitiv mehr punkte
so pass mal auf rpg und in flul
es wäre halt geil wenn ich wenigstens kann könnte zwischendurch
gibt es nicht
auf panzer macht so platt man kriegt übrigens noch nicht mal kill punkte für den repair
champ
du kommst hier nicht rein aber ich habe so viel repair champ gemacht
wenn ich jetzt noch treffen würde
der kollege du kannst mich da mitten rein fahren wie soll ich ihn da retten
repair champ ist on the way hier
hinter uns ist ein eod bot oder
repair champ repair champ
ok ich würde sagen ich habe ich bin zwar nicht der erste mit den punkten aber aber
die runde war eindeutig carried by repair champ oder
ohne repair champ wäre da nicht viel gegangen
wollte nicht mal probieren den server mit viewer zu finden ich glaube ehrlich gesagt
das ist das sind zu 90 prozent viewer auf dem server grad
mvp repair champ gg eats
bringst eine runde kann man noch spielen
ich glaube dann
was mit eod scharf gemacht da ist
ja auch so geile dinge dieser eod bot der ist ja zu 90 prozent useless
aber die 10 prozent woran was bringt ist halt pock noch mal metro ok also metro
ja das sagt auf dem server aber metro und bazaar ist halt die wo die meiste krass action
abgeht
nächstes mal ein mal anderen server wobei morgen ist er eh vorbei morgen gibt es die
poggers
poggers server
ich kann mich schon bewegen
ich bin mal gespannt leute wir dürfen da nicht so viel erwarten einmal die auch benutzen
ich glaube ich habe für die auch gar nichts freigeschaltet ich könnte die scar verwenden
ich könnte die ak verwenden ich könnte
vor nähen aids n a aimed alter n a aimed
alles klar easy easy easy
ok leute wir müssen jetzt
ah shit von wo ist denn der kleist unterwegs
ich wollte jetzt eigentlich schön reinpushen oben in diesen in diesen park
also wenn es bei benis an nicht gute surfer gibt haustich auf jeden fall ein könnt ihr
euch drauf verlassen
poggers hausting mach ich dann
warum warum piekt ihr gleichzeitig
klein pro gamer hier
nein nein nein fällt nicht retzen
ich nehme mich nicht ein
der core gamer jeder typ das ist das ist der deck mit dem mit dem ein 49 trigger script
oder sowas keine ahnung der typ ging gestern auch übelst krass ab
bei keiner ahnung ob ein trigger script wahrscheinlich nicht mal
wahrscheinlich und nicht mal
wahrscheinlich nicht mal aber der ist der geht ab
der geht ab der core gamer die hatten wir gestern auch schon
ich muss mich mal kurz verpissen hier
gucken was da ein a los ist
ohr monkeis gucken euch an alter der core gamer
der wollte es gestern schon so krass wissen
was ist dafür was ist da vorne für pp gar immer am start ach das geht ja in den büschen
ich habe ich vergessen das wird zu anstrengend ich mache nach der ich mach glaube ich mache
nach der runde echt pause guckt euch an ist das normal alter der geht echt ab
der core gamer man die rest auch weiß
die rett das alter schaut es ab
wir sind ein bisschen wir sind mir ein bisschen zu zu sporn rate mäßig unterwegs gerade
wenn da ein paar unsinnig vorne sterben ist halt auch mal schnell vorbei
bewegt mich nicht ja das ist wohl war
haben die eine drohne am start irgendwie die alles spotted
die sind krass drauf gerade wieder obwohl ich glaube die machen eins die machen best
den streamer und dafür pushen sie nicht ich stelle es jetzt einfach hier unten rum im
360 kann mir nichts passieren ich schenke meinen kopf raus und bin tot alter was ist
jetzt gerade los ja fs taske ich auch die sache ist nur die ich ich glaube die sind
bis ich glaube die sind ein bisschen spät dran also ich würde mich gerne eines besseren
belehren lassen das ist huge streams da was ist denn hier los grad ich würde mich wirklich
halter ich bin ich ich bin da und mit ins dauen mit der what the fuck
was origin kostet 39 euro ok wir gucken gleich vorfingen im key auf jenna key shop seite
benefit also es gibt es auf twitch katten kostenlos beide wehren
easy griechtschäme griechtschäme
ok glaube der default first hat am kann schon sein diese als die gegner wollten es gerade
echt wieder wissen aber die haben halt überhaupt nicht objective gespielt
die attack runde noch mal die attack runde metro noch meine maus ist weg kann ich skippen
meine maus ist einfach weg easy maus weg gg nawal dankeschön für den zapp meine maus
ist weg what the fuck game please
vielleicht die maus der nächste runde wieder da aug ich hab für die aug nix freigeschaltet
die aug ironsides ich muss eh morgen wieder alles alter meine maus ist weg ok ich mein
ingame braucht man die maus nicht aber ah jetzt ist die maus wieder da easy oder falsche
richtung das wäre dir mit einem controller nicht
passiert das ist richtig hier wir gehen jetzt zuerst wieder auf a weil a das entscheidende
hier ist alter die suppression meine güte
weiter bei unsere park sind kacke 80 suppression die macht fertig
achtung jolo racer
dreimal ammo was ist denn das leute perks ja nicht sterben nicht sterben alles klar
im overrated she baited
ok ok also ich switch jetzt mal auf oder ich switch nicht
ah shit der default first ist wirklich krasser krasser skiller er
der trifft schon erstaunlich gut aber ich ganz ehrlich wer wirklich ich glaube nicht
dass er cheated das wäre auch das wäre auch total hängen geblieben letztendlich warum
sollte er ja und das kann es dann so ein paar kleinigkeiten eh nicht abmachen
dazu kommt wer in so einem alten game cheated ist wirklich beknackt
ganz im erz ok jetzt kann ich parks ändern customize loadouts sprints cover sprints
der dauermann ist er wieder am start
der dauermann ist er wieder da
er passt auf jeden fall gut auf aber ganz ehrlich das wird man das trifft jeder
der hi happen den kenne ich der ist aus dem chat moin hi happen
ey wisst ihr was mich das gerade wieder dran erinnert wie geil das war wie geil das war
als einfach dieses game angesagt war das war massive poggers
dieses game angesagt war so geil ich konnte einfach content machen zu einem game was ich
gerne spiele und hat unendlich viel zum reden problem ist dass mir die neuen battlefields
nicht mehr gefallen und das battlefield an sich auch ein bisschen flavor of the month
eingebüßt hat battlefield ist ja nicht mehr so angesagt und dazu kommen die neuen battlefields
gefallen mir nicht also was im endeffekt darauf rausläuft dass ja ganz kein battlefield
war und youtube ist auch ein bisschen was anderes
nein nein 1ks beste so ist das immer äußerst nice wenn man sich gegenseitig killt
x fatal ich versuchte zu holen jetzt jetzt haben sie jetzt haben sie alle wieder
angeschaltet die gegner die die drücken die fangen jetzt ins sind an zu drücken
pressure guck sie an
ich muss echt pausen mal ich habe reaction echt wie als wäre ich 36
stell euch das mal vor wo kann man dahin
ich das gibt es nicht kacke im kacke im hättest retten beim ersten mal funktioniert
hätten wir gehabt
da macht er die 60 seht ihr es der q q predator der macht hier was auch immer das bringen
soll aber es ist stylish aus
redator die predator schnuppelmaschine das manche sachen vom krieger war echt schon
heftig cringe manches war echt schon massiv cringe
das hier kommst du dir vor wie ab als spieler spielst du muss am eck ab auf dumm
falsche richtung
die base ist aber echt krass oder ich merke es er wie lange bin ich jetzt on macht mal
einer please abzahlen die map ist auch für 24 geht geht geht 24 32 einzige was halt nicht
geht ist 64 64 geht halt nicht 64 kannst vergessen 48 ist auch noch halbwegs spielbar aber auch
schon nicht mal gut aber 64 ist vorbei
das ist übrigens was was anderen battlefields wirklich fehlt ordentliche line of sight die
durchdacht sind
einer camper man war ich habe ich habe gerade mit dem auge so kurz nach links hingeguckt
wo unser typ gestorben ist und ins und dauerne alter lass mich doch einfach mal aufstehen
please
warte mal wir haben gelegt wir haben gelegt lege henne du lichs alter
gemacht hab das gesehen sneaky lege henne sneaky lege henne
ja ich habe eigentlich gedacht während wir hier action machen pushen die auf der anderen
seite rein aber vergiss es sie können schon mal aufnehmen die runde mal ganz nice rasiert
die runde 50 10 vielleicht ist einfach nur gut aber wir haben gelegt die lege henne ist
real die lege henne ist real wir müssen dahin wir müssen dahin wir müssen dahin wir müssen
dahin wir müssen dahin wir müssen uns sowas von bei ein ordnen in den in den in die bäschten
no paperhands paperhands es war so close
meine güte mega anstrengend mega anstrengend
wir wollten auch eine konsultierlist machen weiß ja ob ich da jetzt noch dass doch brain
aktivität für habe dati fall first er hat gaming socken gaming stuhl gaming tisch gaming
crib fps freaks gfuel alles hatte der alles aber leute ultra nice fast 300 leute am start
für battlefield 3 das ist äußerst poggers sehr nice schön dass ihr alle am start seid
by the way habe ich schon mal gesagt dass es aktuell mit amazon prime kostenlos battlefield
3 auf twitch gibt und wenn ihr gerade dabei seid und euren amazon account e verbindet
mit twitch könnt ihr mir auch gleich in primes habt alle also wenn euch das ganze gefällt
ich meine das geld für das game habt ihr eh gespart big brain move sichert euch plus
50 iq ja es ist witzig wenn ich mal auf twitch gucke battlefield 3 ich bin also bei mir sind
irgendwie 90 prozenter zuschauer lull weh kommt mal nachher kommen auch ein paar andere
hey der kommt mir bekannt vor ist der nicht öfters ist der typ nicht auch öfters bei
bei dings bei diesem top play channel am start
und sorry an alle die ich vielleicht übersehen habe während ich hier am start war in game
ich gucke mal kurz
der eichler 16 monat dankeschön gar nicht gesehen nachwahl hatte ich
ja sorry falls ich irgendwas übersehen habe der martin hat abonniert für 14 monate
ja also nice dass ihr alle am start gewesen seid leute massive
nee nee was ich würde sagen wir hosten den jetzt auch major den ich major mature audience
wir hosten ihn jetzt mal hier easy easy host easy live nee raid wir raiden wir raiden
ja wir raiden ja
raid sag
hallo ich kann nicht copy pasten dann muss ich es schreiben t c o t c bounty alles klar
ich kenne den stream nicht aber andere battlefield leute muss man muss man supporten
unser kanal richtet sich an erwachsene also leute benehmt euch benehmt euch
also leute wir sehen uns machts gut bis denn see you